this must be the old Amber mines  [Music]  I think the thing that makes people love  dinosaur movies in general is that we  know they were real they're not aliens  they're not monsters they were real  animals that existed on this planet so  when you see them on screen you feel  like you're watching something that's  actually happening the great thing about  those early jurassics was that we had  these great creatures so that when you  cut to something that's computer  generated you believe it because you've  just been so close to it to a real thing  that's real three-dimensional thing that  you believe implicitly the next image  and I was amazed actually to get back  onto this set to realize that we were  doing this in the old school way with  fantastic creatures